right listen I need some help I came to
make the most amazing pumpkin soup film
by me it's very heavy but it is gonna be
absolutely delicious right they always
tell okay if it's ripe it would be on
there
what does that sound like yeah drums
that's right okay push your thumb in
there should be just a little bit soft
right at the bottom the root first of
all we're cut it in half and very
carefully just cut through I'm using a
French pumpkin but these versatile
vegetables come in all shapes and sizes
and colors at this time of year they're
nutty sweetness is ideal for warming
soups curries andros wait to see what
happens when we open this up all right
Holly that's for you now this is where
is gonna get a little bit gory okay you
get your hands and you scrape the seeds
out rub them together just getting a
little clean nice and gently good yeah
nice look at that good you mean yeah
come on Holly that's it into the water
now what's the seeds around we're going
to toast them in the oven a little snack
so this is a very nice way I'm not
wasting anything get your fingers right
in there Tilley there you go once the
pumpkin seeds are out score the flesh to
help it roast and absorb flavor season
and have a generous amount of rosemary
take the garlic rubbed on the outside
serve perfuse the inside then at a
larger glug of olive oil and as the
garlic grouse with the rosemary it's
sweet almost buttery nutty taste will
mellow and flavor the pumpkin all the
C's done good
after the pumpkin seeds have been
cleaned dry and season them ready for
the oven
now they go roast in the oven for about
45 to 50 minutes good now when you smell
the house in about five minutes time
trade please Holly so beautiful straight
ahead right
well done big question have you wrapped
mommy's present yet yeah let's go I'll
give you a hand with quick measurements
tell that garlic smells amazing
[Music]
holy chili where Tommy he's going to a
party soon to party oh no any boys there
I don't know Oh y'all so diplomatic
right look they are now toast it do that
I haven't what taste one of those nice
yeah but look at this wow that looks
amazing
and that is a roasted pumpkin now you
put the spoon down the size okay
scooping out will have lovely roast
pumpkin we don't waste anything
you know skinny all into Center
roasted her pumpkin intensifies the rich
sweet flavor of its flesh which is
lovely for soups but also great as a
filling for ravioli or making a
delicious mash with butter nutmeg and
salt and pepper
that's the pumpkin don't now I want you
to do is get these mushrooms here and
just peel them lengthwise okay onto the
plate okay and I'll get my onion chopped
olive all in okay nice and generous the
olive all cuz what this soup do really
nice and velvety onions in and then
scoop out a wonderful garlic has been
roasted on the pumpkin mmm lovely so bit
of nutmeg on top of the onions onions
garlic and nutmeg yeah
and now pumpkin and you would come in
handy somewhere
this little baby it's for you
perfect
now I want you just to grate some
parmesan like that for me okay just have
her start roasting off the parmesan as
well so we got this really nice rich
delicious pumpkin
chromosomes brilliant for enriched in
this soup it's mellow camel flavor and
saltiness provide a lovely balance to
the sweet pumpkin now always do let's
get all that in there
yes yes
[Music]
look at now that roasted sort of cheesy
rosemary garlicky yeah
olive oily beautiful so far nothing's
gone to waste
we'd used the hot pumpkin now I'm gonna
have the stock my hand was cooked in the
dis master doesn't it smells Christmassy
delicious recipe that's just from
cooking our ham bring that up to the
boil and we'll let that cook out for ten
minutes pretty really important that was
boarding when the cream goes in okay you
see the color lining that's gonna go
really nice rich creamy taste okay now
we're gonna so do the mushrooms good
with olive all in there yeah get nice
and hot we'll go first with the
pompadour more and you go good girl
then the getting the top in and then
finely chop out nice lovely I'm going to
put a little bit of butter in there
opiate
and live ambassador nice I love that the
complex flavor of wild mushrooms but we
can't get them Chester or filled
mushrooms still deliver great taste
mushrooms work really well with pumpkin
because they have a warm earthy flavor
that complements the pumpkin beautifully
so mushrooms into the center yeah from
there we got the parmesan and just peel
nice long layers watch very carefully
no just sit on top why the parmesan
helps to season the mushroom and really
give off an amazing flavor okay we're
gonna blend the soup and all we're gonna
do is 1/2 fill the blender so the soup
gets really nicely aerated now there's a
bit of a naughty chefs trick a little
knob of butter in there just in Tom so
when it blends it gets really nice and
smooth lid on onto the blender and we'll
just pulse it on and off first
nice Wow and this as a moment we'll be
waiting for just one side of the bowl so
that's daddy's portion that this little
bit yours mmm now it'll taste blow
gently
hmm
[Music]